>> Greg: WELCOME BACK.
LIZ WARREN KEEPS IT CREEPY,
TWEETING NONSENSE FROM HER TV
THAT'S GOOD.
PEOPLE LIKE GRIMES.
THE INTERNET GROANS.
MASSACHUSETTS SENATOR AND
CHEROKEE NATION ICON.
HERE SHE IS THROWING IN ACTS.
I SHOULD'VE SAID TOMAHAWK.
>> Tyrus: YOU DID.
THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZING.
>> Greg: SHE TWEETED THIS.
ON INDIGENOUS PEOPLE SAY WE
CELEBRATE THE CONTRIBUTIONS,
THEIR EXTRAORDINARY RESILIENCE
AND THE RICH CULTURES OF TRIBAL
NATIONS AND NATIVE COMMUNITIES.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HONORING HIS
PROMISES AND NATIVE PEOPLES.
I HAVEN'T SEEN A TWEET THAT
FASTENS RACHEL DOLEZAL WISH
TESSA HAPPY BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
WARREN CLAIMED NATIVE AMERICAN
HISTORY EVEN THOUGH HER BLOOD
TEST CAME BACK AS MAYONNAISE.
THIS HUMAN BUMPER STICKER THINKS
SHE'S QUALIFIED TO GO ALL IN FOR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES' DAY WHICH
HAS REPLACED COLUMBUS DAY IN
SOME CITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
CASINOS.
MORE COULD BE ON THE WAY.
THE PARADE WENT ON AS USUAL IN
NEW YORK, DEMOCRAT LAWMAKERS
INTRODUCED A BILL TO ERASE IT AS
A STATE HOLIDAY AND REPLACE IT
WITH INDIGENOUS PEOPLES' DAY.
EVEN HALLOWEEN FUN IS TOAST.
IN PHILLY, THE BIRTHPLACE OF
PUNCHING, ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
CANCELED ITS ANNUAL HALLOWEEN
PARADES FOR NOT BEING INCLUSIVE
ENOUGH.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM IN PHILLY?
HOLY CRAP.
APPARENTLY IT'S A PROBLEM
BECAUSE NOT EVERYONE CELEBRATE
HALLOWEEN AND THOSE KIDS HAD TO
SIT IN THE LIBRARY DURING PAST
PARADES.
IT'S CRUEL CONSIDERING THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN TAUGHT TO READ.
SINCE ITS PHILLY, KIDS ARE STILL
ALLOWED TO WEAR MASKS WHEN THEY
ROB CONVENIENCE STORES.
ANYTHING MORE TO ADD?
>> I STAND BY MY WORDS.
I'M NOT THE TYPE OF PERSON TO
GIVE YOU SOMETHING AND THEN TAKE
IT BACK.
IT'S BEEN MANY MOONS SINCE MY
FAILED PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
WHEN I BRAVELY BATTLED FELLOW
WOMEN OF COLOR TULSI GABBARD AND
BETO O'ROURKE.
ALL AMERICANS DESERVE A PUFF ON
THE PIPE OF PEACE.
YOU DON'T NEED A RESERVATION.
I'VE GOT TO GO.
I AM TO THE OPTOMETRIST FOR MY
VISION QUEST.
>> Greg: MERCEDES, WHY IS THE
LEFT SO OBSESSED WITH CHANGING
THINGS?
THEY'VE GOT TO CHANGE
COLUMBUS DAY.
>> Mercedes: IS A VERY BROAD
QUESTION.
>> Greg: I COULD'VE SAID THAT
ABOUT THE A BLOCK.
WHAT'S YOUR ANSWER.
>> Mercedes: I BELIEVE
DR. FAUCI IS IN CHARGE OF THE
HALLOWEEN PARADE IN PHILADELPHIA
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT IT TO
HAPPEN.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
THESE POOR KIDS.
THEY HAVE SUFFERED ENOUGH.
THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
HAVING ISSUES IN SCHOOL.
ON TOP OF THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
TAKE AWAY HALLOWEEN.
THEY'VE ALREADY TAKEN AWAY
CHRISTMAS AND THANKSGIVING UNDER
THE FAUCI RULE.
LET THE KIDS BE KIDS.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE TIME WHEN
IT WAS A JOYFUL TIME TO GET
TOGETHER WITH YOUR FRIENDS,
DRESS HOWEVER HE WANTED TO DRESS
AND GO GET CANDY.
THEY MADE EVERYTHING INTO A
POLITICAL FIGHT, POLITICAL
DIVISION AND IT'S AN OUTRAGE.
ELIZABETH WARREN, I WANT TO SAY
ONE THING.
SHE SHOULD JUST CLAIM, NOW THAT
YOU CAN IDENTIFY AS ANYTHING,
BECOME AN ITALIAN-AMERICAN AND
SUPPORT COLUMBUS DAY.
THAT'S WHEN I WOULD DO.
>> Greg: SHE WOULD BE A
TERRIBLE ITALIAN.
I DON'T THINK SHE CAN COOK.
>> Tyrus: WHEN SOMEBODY USES
MINORITIES FOR FINANCIAL GAIN
AND IS ABLE TO COME BACK AND
HONOR IT IN EVERYONE'S OKAY WITH
IT, ONE HAS NEVER BEEN --
SHOULDN'T SHE HAVE BEEN
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ON THE HILL?
LIKE YOU USED TO PRETEND TO BE
SOMETHING YOU'RE NOT TO GET
JOBS, TO GET FAVORS, ELECTIONS.
YOU DEFRAUDED YOUR VOTERS.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE VOTING
FOR SOMEONE WHO WAS
NATIVE AMERICAN AND WAS PROUD OF
THEIR HERITAGE.
IN A WAY, ISN'T THAT SOME FORM
OF CRIME?
BUT YET FACTS MEAN ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING BECAUSE THERE IS NO
CONSEQUENCES.
SHE COULD MAKE JOKES ABOUT IT.
I DON'T THINK THAT PEOPLE WHO
LOST THEIR JOBS AND THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES LOST THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE OF HER PLAYING AROUND
WITH THE APPLICATIONS KNOWING
DAMN WELL WHAT SHE WAS DOING, I
DON'T THINK THEY WERE LAUGHING.
EVERYTHING COMES DOWN TO COMING
LOOK FOR JUNK THE JOKE IS THE
WOKE.
YOU SAID IT TODAY.
NOBODY WANTS TO WORK.
THEY WANT TO END IT AND START
THEIR OWN.
WHY?
I GUARANTEE YOU THERE'S GOING TO
BE A FACT-FINDING COMMITTEE
BASED ON INDIGENOUS PEOPLE DAY
AND THERE'S GOING TO BE A
COMMITTEE AND THEIR BODIES HAVE
TO GET PAID TO RESEARCH TO FIND
OUT JUST HOW BAD IT WAS.
THEY CAN MAKE MONEY.
THEY GET STUFF AND SPEAKING
ENGAGEMENTS OR WHATEVER,
BOOSTERS, CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS.
THAT'S WHY THEY DON'T WANT TO
MERGE.
THEY WANT TO STOP IT SO THEY CAN
MAKE THEIR OWN.
>> Greg: THEY ARE COMING FOR
HALLOWEEN.
THEY MIGHT AS WELL JUST COME FOR
YOUR BIRTHDAY.
HALLOWEEN.
>> Kat: HALLOWEEN IS ALWAYS
STEALING THE THUNDER FOR MY
BIRTHDAY.
>> Greg: SO YOU WANTED GONE.
>> Kat: CHANGED TO MY
BIRTHDAY.
CELEBRATED NATIONALLY.
I FEEL FOR THESE KIDS.
ONE DAY A YEAR THAT YOU DON'T
FEEL INCLUDED, YOU'RE DOING
OKAY.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> Kat: FOR ME WAS TELLING
TIME THEY COULDN'T SEE WHO I
WAS.
THE ONLY TIME I WAS OKAY.
I HAVE MOVED ON.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY ABSURD BUT
EVERYTHING WILL BE CANCELED.
WE WILL ALL JUST SIT THERE.
>> Greg: I'VE BEEN WAY AHEAD
OF THAT TREND BECAUSE ALL I DO
IS SIT.
THAT'S ALL I DO.
THEY MIGHT LISTEN.
MY MAMA DIDN'T LET ME CELEBRATE
HALLOWEEN SO I HAVE SOME
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA FROM THIS.
THANKFULLY MY DAD WAS SUPER COOL
SO HE KEPT A WEREWOLF MASK IN
THE TOOLBOX OF HIS TRUCK 3965
DAYS A YEAR SO HE COULD TAKE ME
TO MY GRANDPARENTS ON HALLOWEEN
WE WOULD GO TRICK-OR-TREATING.
I HAVE BEEN LIKE, I HAD OVERALLS
ON ONE DAY.
I HAD MY NINJA TURTLE PAJAMAS
ON.
NINJA TURTLE WEREWOLF.
EVERY VERSION OF THE WEREWOLF
YOU CAN THINK OF.
LET THE KID CELEBRATE HALLOWEEN.
MY MAMA WOULD GIVE ME ALL THOSE
HALLOWEEN'S FOR ALL THE HEATHEN
THINGS SHE KNOWS THAT I DO NOW.
SHE WOULD'VE JUST LET ME HAVE
HALLOWEEN I WOULD PROBABLY BE
PREACHING SOMEWHERE.
INSTEAD I BORROWED THE SHIRT
FROM ELIZABETH WARREN AND I COME
ON THE SHOW AND F-BOMBS.